ça se voit
[Musique]
non mais c'est vrai il ya six ans pour
toile et il est raciste son âge
wow il est déjà raciste surtout que
c'est interdit en france de faire des
statistiques ethniques
et surtout je pense quitte à aller au
bout du sondage autant écrire les juifs
avec des doigts crochus les arabes avec
des tapis volant s'est juste excellence
et nauséabonde nous sommes français déjà
appelé les gens les musulmans les
maghrébins et noir voilà c'est ce que
les gens qui ont été qui ont été créés
ont été questionnés c'est script en son
art mais moi j'ai une bo d une minorité
de privilégiés en france ils ont
globalement fermer des usines en france
ils ont fait baisser les salaires ils
ont fait venir au ici des gens qu'ils
sous payent parce que la plupart du
temps les migrants ne sont pas déclarés
n'exporte pas sur l'éducation fabrique
mais bien serait ce pas le jdd et la
pravda de macron monsieur belattar était
le bouffon du roi il a servi macron ça
va dans le bon sens c'était de bosser
pour les nommer guillaume bigot
c'est pas le débat 2e 6 cd je trouvais
déjà des macros le sec sur ces news est
un long tunnel où vous dites que de la
merde moi ici je dois vous répondre 1 2
vous porter très bien votre nom je vous
dire le troisième point mais beaucoup de
gens ici on a pas comment j'ai des potes
désaccord avec plein de chroniqueurs que
les choses soient bien claires mais ça
nous empêche pas d'avoir un but commun
c'est que le fait que les gens puissent
vivre ensemble dans un pays qui porte
soit 165 millions de personnes vous vous
réveillez le matin avec des lubies en
disant il faut casser du [ __ ] faut
casser du [ __ ] roi où va leur envoyer
mes amis je voudrais lisant les
terminaux à me dire ça j'ai dit ça en
plus on se le tient une jeune et 10 min
dîner
je vous laisse savourer votre exploit
quand victoire vous l'aviez dit un
triomphe modeste
il a le triomphe modeste fabrice di
vizio votre analyse mon analyse c'est
que il faut c'est pas une vie pas de
victoria paix doit arrêter ça va mais
non non vraiment pas moi je pense que
tout ce qui peut nous sortir cette
épidémie est le bienvenu a bien sûr mais
à condition de le faire avec précaution
précisément et que un acte médical ça
s'improvise jamais vous voyez moi j'ai
un peu personnel qui qui multiplie
moment tu m'emmerdes quoi pour faire
simple c'est quand on dit vaccinez vous
pour retourner au restaurant ça va pas
les gars jr on se vaccine parce que
c'est important pour se protéger pour
protéger les autres mais on se vaccine
pas pourquoi tourner au restaurant voilà
je veux qu'on en fait un peu trop avec
elle qu'est ce que vous en pensez
manas ne sais pas moi je vous dire
honnêtement ce qui me m'interpelle et
j'ai fait téléphoné à twitter ce matin
j'ai interpellé de beau matin en voyant
qu'effectivement le compte de neda était
suspendu ce que je déplore c'est le
manque de transparence dans l'action
modération twitter souvient que à
l'heure actuelle on a pas de règles
claires qui nous disent que vous soyez
milla géraldine maillet cyril hanouna
marlène schiappa si vous êtes insultant
c'est participer à un raid numérique
votre qu'on sera supprimé et c'est
normal il ya des millions de tweets
c'est très compliqué mais justement
c'est gérable si on s'en donne les
moyens moi je pense que comme dirait
spiderman un grand pouvoir implique de
grandes responsabilités
twitter les grands auteurs twitter a un
grand pouvoir et dont je pense qu'ils
doivent aussi avoir la responsabilité de
suspendre des décomptes
quand vous entendez que il ya des
personnes qui existe qui a comme une
injustice mode bridge qu'est ce que vous
leur répondez pas encore une fois est ce
que je disais avant la pause c'est à
dire que quand la décision a été prise
il y avait encore des critères en
ile-de-france qui permettait d'espérer
confine pas c'était pas le cas dans le
nord pas de calais c'est comme ça qu'il
ya des décisions qui ont été prises ces
vaccins supplément vélo vous avez des
pensées vous avez dépendra évidemment de
tout vous voyez bien que la situation va
évoluer je vous dis après vous continuez
votre copie n'est pas paris je m'en fous
royalement par les sages de l'union
sept combats de nous embêter et qu'on
nous dès qu'on arrête je suis ce cercle
le week-end sonne qui nous regardent qui
se sont fait vacciner avec ce vaccin
astrazeneca comme géraldine maillet elle
nous l'a dit ce week-end
est-ce qu'ils doivent craindre des
effets secondaires ou est-ce qu'au bout
de quelques jours vous avez vu que
normalement si on fait pas de thrombose
dans les voilà partis derrière on est
sorties d'affaires
mais voilà géraldine maillet par exemple
sorti d'affaires surtout je le redis 15
millions de personnes entre le royaume
uni et l'europe et 54 thrombose donc
c'est extrêmement rare en fait on a deux
on a on n'a qu'un seul objectif quand on
commence ce métier c'est de faire rêver
alors avec ses atouts certains c'est par
leur physique d'autres c'est par leur
tenue d'autres c'est par le rire mais en
tout cas on n'a qu'une mission c'est
celle là et on nous répète et roselyne
bachelot en fait partie parce qu'elle
défend
quoi qu'on dise quoi qu'on fasse elle
défend la culture et on dit qu'on est là
pour être essentiel et ce qu'on a vu
samedi soir c'était tout sauf
l'essentiel jamais il a eu de nom il
était extrêmement pudique on m'a posé
des questions sur un rapport physique
moelleux la première et 30 que j'ai eue
de ppda 17 ans c'est en janvier 2005
quand je lui ai annoncé que j'avais
trouvé un éditeur comme mon livre allait
sortir
patrick s'est levé il était très ému
parce qu'il savait que moi je me battais
pour ça et il m'a pris dans ses bras et
pour moi que ppda me prendre dans ses
bras après 16 ans j'aurais pu rester
huit heures j'étais hyper bien élu après
huit journées peut avoir une aventure
avec lui non faut savoir qu'après mon
passage chez vous et un journaliste qui
m'ont appelé et il m'a dit j'ai lu votre
livre
j'ai analysé moi je crois contre les
lignes vous devriez dire les choses mais
c'est pas vrai j'ai pas avec lui ça en
fait encore des dizaines parce que ces
dizaines de témoignages il existe il
existe moi même j'ai des témoignages de
plusieurs camarades qui étaient allés
voir patrick poivre d'avor qu'elle soit
journaliste à tf1 ou pas et qui m'en ont
parlé qui m'ont raconté on est une
journaliste à vsd qui s'est plaint de
patrick poivre d'arvor et qui était
venue me raconter parce qu'elle avait
été traumatisée parce qu'elle est en
adoration devant lui donc oui quand la
jeune fille l'émoustiller beaucoup il
pouvait avoir des gestes qu'ils
pouvaient aller pour être aimable disons
être très mal interprété
j'ai trop peur de souffrir oui c'est
vrai j'étais très très très forte qu'est
ce qui s'est passé est ce que vous avez
des expériences difficiles mais à chaque
fois parce que vous savez la mort quand
on se donne comme ça complètement c'est
c'est arrivé quand ça finit mal
mais comme chacun sait effrayant cette
seule bernard oui je suis seul et je le
regrette et vu mon caractère ça va pas
s'arranger
vraiment vous pouvez penser que vous
terminerez le sol oui et je suis
parfaitement choqué et je me vient ici
de manière très claire les nazis et les
néo nazis n'ont rien à faire dans
l'armée française
parce que d'ailleurs comme les policiers
raciste quand on porte l'uniforme
on a une responsabilité on représente la
france on représente la république
et puis on n'en représentent nous tous
les français donc on a une conçoit un
soldat vous avez vu qu'il y en a
beaucoup quand même
on en recense combien épisode en gagnant
recensé plusieurs dizaines inacceptable
oui quand j'avais 15 ans j'ai vu un
opuscule skinheads ça m'a attiré tu te
retrouves dans un groupe comme ça avec
une telle haine que je moi je me
rappelle ça m'arrivait de sauter à pieds
joints sur la tête de deux personnes jeu
ont massacré des gens toute la journée
c'était un plaisir en gav est une telle
violence en moi et que j'essayais
véritablement de la dominer mais parfois
quand elle ressortait c'est comme s'il y
avait 10 personnes en moins j'avais plus
de sentiment en moi et quand mon pote il
est tombé comme ça il y en a eu qui a
pris une balle dans la tête quoi est
l'hôte est devenue handicapée bassam a
fait heureusement on ressortir des
sentiments et j'ai beaucoup pleuré j'ai
beaucoup prié en fait pour pourvoir ont
changé fois et cette bataille à
l'intérieur elle m'a fait voir
véritablement c'est qu'avant j'étais
faible en fait et la vie spirituelle ça
m'a permis de me battre à l'intérieur
maintenant je peux tolérer je peux
pardonner je peux aimer même chargement
ou sentais bien maintenant un
complètement
m bruzac ce que vous dites - j'ai
entendu un mot et je partage tout à fait
la vision le mot échec cirque
aujourd'hui parler de confinement au
bout d'un an et un échec est un échec
politique c'est un échec sanitaire
médical et je crois que cela nous sommes
parfaitement d'accord fin le 2 caps
convient de prendre la nouvelle du
confinement 507 dans la poche et a alors
je sais pas si vous êtes comme moi mais
quand tu la prend dans la gueule
cette envie de dire où ça fait mal j'ai
quelque chose à vous dire
lundi il y aura tjrs aux verts pour le
plus grand bonheur des téléspectateurs
je me passerais de vous je me passerais
de vous
après 21h15 ouais ouais je serai bien
sur ce plateau est ce que tes pump et
continuera ta balle je vous le dis les
dernières on sait moins vu parce qu'il y
avait le profil mon imac avec quatre
personnes n'étaient pas sur les missions
et moi je les ai vécus très très mal et
on se pose beaucoup de questions c'est
vrai c'est une vraie angoisse et on se
dit qu'est ce qu'on a fait de mal qu'est
ce qu'on n'a pas pris la mesure c'est
très vrai rien fait de mal c'est
vraiment voilà c'est aussi voilà ccc
voilà les missions parfois vous avez vu
l'émission elle a plein de visages
j'aimerais voilà et est plein de design
différent donc quelquefois on a besoin
de visages de deux tailles de tels
profils d'autres profils c'est vrai qu'à
l'équipe change peu en ce moment parce
que l'affairé qu'on a trouvé une vitesse
de croisière un but est de croisière
incroyable mais bien sûr il y en a qu'on
voit moins en ce moment qu'ils
reviendront très très vite et qui me
manque
aussi je vous dis j'aurais dit je
voulais ajouter quelque chose monsieur
mais c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
parce que c'est quand même un métier
malgré tout on amour du désir des autres
le désir de l'autre en l'occurrence et
vous cyril donc forcément quand on n'est
pas appelée autour de la table se
produire je vous aime pas non mais bien
sûr que non mais sauf qu'on le prend
parfois on se remet en question sur di
castro n'a pas bien fait ce qu'on n'a
pas fait une bonne émission ou n'être
qu' on n'a pas parlé
enfin on n'a pas parlé en de bons
moments voilà dont on doute et ça nous
ça nous remet aussi un petit coup de
pression et moi je voudrais dire aussi
puisque ça on est dans un contexte
politique que aujourd'hui encore plus
cette année je mesure la chance que j'ai
de pouvoir sortir de la maison d'aller
bosser de retrouver une équipe des
collègues d'avoir des gens qui nous
pompent sommes des techniciens des gens
qui nous maquis qui me coiffe je trouve
qu'on est mordu mon extrêmement chanceux
de pouvoir sortir de sa maison et le
palais ton télétravail et voilà je
trouve qu'on est des privilégiés excusez
moi monsieur rabiboche au numéro 12 a
rien demandé
c'est la rumeur sélection je crois
qu'ils avaient un problème monsieur oui
j'ai un problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui
notre écosystème il est profondément
bouleversé et vous faites la diarrhée
verbale et qui a défendu corps et je
sais que juridiquement vous vous pourrez
d'aidé mais qui sont bord du gouffre des
entreprises qui n'ont plus de fonds et
qui ont plus de thunes et qui ont des
trous dans la raquette et vous les
emmenez sur des procédures qui dure dix
comme ça je ne suis pas de 1576 fabrice
tourre attaquer nos mines m
je tenais foyer je croyais que beaucoup
et je vais m'abaisser à un niveau comme
ça je termine je termine avec la
carrière qu'est la mienne enfin portait
pas le nom qu'il voulait réagir
là-dessus
[Musique]